my first 18 years were spent in a
housing project but I decided that I was
going to go to college I applied to
Harvard and Princeton and Yale got
accepted with a that all of those places
and ended up going to Hillsdale those
four years were some of the best years
of my life my professors had the last
thing and a continuing impression on me
one was Ray lung Quist ray and his
father were both composers and I took
great music under him all I knew was
rock n roll and rhythm and blues he
introduced me to classical music and
it's been a passion of mine ever since
my first job was at the University of
Pittsburgh and I just fell in love with
it I didn't realize that I was good at
it and loved it until I actually began
to teach I retired but in my spare time
I tutor kids over at the local community
college now I'm working one-on-one with
students who struggles and to watch them
get a concept that they never got it is
it is an experienced at every teacher
cherishes I received a call from a
Michael Campbell as you would probably
recall there was a Catholic school we
have spent two and a half million
dollars to refurbishing it and we're
considering naming it after you now this
school is literally right across the
street from where I grew up I can let
out of my old front window and see the
lloyd barn charter school it is probably
the greatest honor I haven't received
find something that you like and
hopefully it'll also be something that
is useful and somebody will pay you for
it but if you want to be successful and
enjoy this life firing first of all
something you like to do